Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we are going to absolutely destroy
this virtual bunny. And then, inflate this cat
until it becomes… a bit of a chonker. And, I hope
you like dumplings, because we’ll also be able to
start a cooking show in a virtual world. For
instance, we can now squash and wrap and pinch
and squeeze. And this is a computer
graphics paper, so let’s smash these
things for good measure. There we go. Add
some more. And the meal is now ready. Enjoy!
This is all possible through this new paper
that is capable of creating physics simulations
with drastic geometry changes. And when I say
drastic, I really mean it. And looking through
the results, this paper feels like it can do
absolutely anything. It promises a technique
called Injective deformation processing. What
does all this mean? It means great news. Finally,
when we do these crazy experiments, things
don’t turn inside out, and the geometry
does not overlap. Wanna see what these
overlaps looks like? Well, here it is.
And, luckily, we don’t have to worry about
this phenomenon with this new technique.
Not only when inflating, but, it also works
correctly when we start deflating things. Now,
talking about overlaps, let’s see this animation
sequence simulated with a previous method.
Oh no! The belly is not moving,
and, my goodness. Look at that.
It gets even worse. What is even
worse than a belly that does not move?
Of course, intersection artifacts. Now, what you
will see is not a re-simulation of this experiment
from scratch with this with the new method,
no-no. Even better. We give this flawed
simulation to the new technique, and…yes, it
can even repair it! Wow. An absolute miracle.
No more self-intersections, and finally, the
belly is moving around in a realistic manner.
And, while we find out whether this armadillo
simulated with the new method is dabbing,
or if it is just shy, let’s talk about how long
we have to wait for a simulation like this.
All nighters? No, not at all! The font inflation
examples take roughly half a second per frame,
that is unbelievable, and it goes up to 12 minutes
per frame, which is required for the larger
deformation experiments. Repairing an
already existing, flawed simulation
also takes a similar amount of time.
So, what about this armadillo? Yes,
that is definitely a shy armadillo. So, from
now on, we can apply drastic geometry changes
in our virtual worlds, and I am sure that two more
papers down the line, all this will be possible in
real time. Real-time dumplings in a virtual world?
Yes please, sign me up! What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!